in the language of the US Department of
Defense
these are unidentified aerial phenomena
videos which add fuel to the belief of
song we are not alone the first incident
was filmed off the California coast in
2004 an oval shape hovering and in the
words of the Navy pilot who recorded
this not behaving by the normal laws of
physics 2015 pilots flying like the East
Coast of America
spotted this again it's speed and
movement apparently astounding
experienced air crews that same year
racing across the surface of the ocean
something that it took some skill to
capture all of these videos have been
leaked in the past but the US government
now confirms they are genuine in a
statement the Department of Defense said
it was releasing the videos in order to
clear up any misconceptions by the
public on whether or not the footage
that's been circulating was real or
whether or not there is more to the
videos the aerial phenomena observed in
these videos they say remain
characterized as unidentified those
who've actually been to space are
skeptical about what the videos reveal
these objects are probably some kind of
secret military program and what these
pilots saw were you know we're real they
saw them when they they filmed and
photographed them and the Pentagon I'm
assuming Declassified them because there
was a lot of speculation going out there
they had already been leaked so why not
come out and say okay these these films
are genuine they do exist but we don't
know what they are of course the US has
a long history of reported UFO sightings
this image captured by a couple in
Oregon in 1950 regarded as one of the
most significant they were certain this
was a UFO
and the Nevada desert continues to
attract those who believe seriously or
not that area 51 houses crashed alien
spacecraft and their occupants with the
world gripped by more earthbound
concerns right now these videos will for
many confirm what they've always
believed that the truth is out there
Greg Milan Sky News Los Angeles